sai cosa fai così mette guarda altro
labirinto del fauno amica di vita
ciao a tutti i benvenuti al nuovo video
siamo qui i compagni e dj's air che ho
utilizzato come cavia sacrificale per
questa idea ho preso con di vari
prodotti di bellezza ma la maschera per
mani una maschera per i piedi e poi una
maschera per la faccia che si chiama
maschere anche se quella mente questi
anche io sai la mattina ma partiamo coi
piedi devo togliermi le calze che
scherzi come faranno sciolto un cappello
ha mai e che noi facciamo la cultura di
aguilar aspetto estate 7 statali
c'è una cosa non abbia fatto open e poi
alla chiudi avrebbe non debba salaria
deve rimanere come si nello spazio
praticamente squisitamente spediscono
sulla luna tra infilava scrivendo la
clip che cosa diventa più sei quello che
sei giocato quello che i filari nella
padella del tubo il tono c'è la tua fini
le allora il giocattolo rituffa cevico
sì io non so che il giocattolo nice
si ispirava nell'albero in un tubo e la
tele pompava
e allora vai ai schizzato un botto sta
mettendo il coperchio ma tanti gorizia
commestibile
no assolutamente vendono questa roba che
ti prende ti scava il google apre
dentario rendine come la tua moglie amy
chiudere la bocca pc alla bocca ap e
dall'altro lato
no ragazzi questa è difficile questo e
molto di più che schifo che schifo di
riuscire a giocare al tubo cioè che tipo
di frutto di ok tempo finito a fare il
mio vedere una staffa cosa ne frega a me
belle adesso questo di vito molière di
rock you che l'onorevole per contatto
ragazzo robin per batman e magari mi
assume nascono come fa questa cosa non
esce la sera si trovano in casa tra
quattro donne si mettono sta roba si
divertendoti 15 toni punta azzardare a
togliere questa cosa dei piedi ma che
schifo che maschera facciale
sembra evidente un dato sicuro che tipo
di film non avrebbe capito da capire
benissimo insieme a tipo non affidano ai
aiutare mamma mia mi sento hannibal
lecter si è rotta no grazie agli occhi
ma io lo sono del vincolo l'abito che i
capelli la corda sai cosa sei così mette
guarda altro labirinto del fauno sarebbe
sempre il mostro diarie per quello che
ti prende tutto capito sono una schedina
facciamo sempre più fantasma dell'opera
per prendi un altro roberta si muovono
altri 20 minuti per queste e adesso di
massa delle intese jazz senti la
giovinezza che sta arrivando
devo dire la maschera se vuoi tutto
sembrava fatto una parte di fitch e con
me semplice 0 pure tolgono mi ha mai
fatto giocarci partito li ha posti
guanti ma a mio avviso di operare bene
sul massimo ma in realtà questa prima
capire però date delle maschere degli
uomini quello che faranno
infatti la data che stabiliti poco dai
su si si lasci entrare il prodotto e lo
siamo arrivati finalmente alla fine di
questo video le mie conclusioni sono
maschere sono una rottura
andate sul canale di cesar che vi metto
qua sotto ti ringrazio per aver
dimostrato quanto sei inabile alla vita
chiede funzione che si chiede pazzesco
fai un like col piede di così
mettete like e iscrivetevi al questo
canale e soprattutto scriveteci altri
suggerimenti per the video in futuro qua
sotto ciao ragazzi